PROFESSOR: Now let me
conclude for a few minutes
by introducing the idea of how
we're going to perturb things.
So how are we going to set
up our perturbation theory?
So for a perturbation theory
we will do the following.
We will take our system
and introduce again--
so setting up the
perturbation expansion.
So we want to give you just an
idea of what we're going to do.
So H of t is going to be H
of 0 plus delta of H of t.
And now your lambda is going
to be treated as small.
So again, we're going to use
a power series expansion,
and everything is going
to depend on lambda.
And we're going to think
coefficients in that way.
We're going to work with
the state psi tilde.
You remember, if
you know psi tilde,
you put an e to the minus ih 0t
over H bar and you can get H.
So we'll set the
perturbation for psi tilde.
And it will have
a zeroth part that
is time dependent plus a first
part that is time dependent.
Every term is going to be time
dependent in the perturbation.
And what was our
Schroedinger equation?
Our Schroedinger equation was
ih bar d dt of psi tilde of t
was delta H, like
that, times psi of t.
But we need to change
things a little bit.
We replace delta H
by lambda delta H.
So now it's going to
have a lambda here.
So I now need to
plug in this thing,
which is not going
to be too difficult.
It's easier than what we did in
time independent perturbation
theory.
d dt of psi 0--
let me not put the time
dependence in the case psi 1
lambda square psi 2.
And this is equal to lambda
delta H bar psi tilde again.
So it's psi 0 plus psi
1 plus those terms.
So for here we'll just
read the first few terms.
They're pretty easy.
There's not much of
a lambda thing there.
So what do we get?
Terms without lambda.
ih bar d dt of psi
tilde 0 of t equals 0.
This is lambda to the 0.
That's the only term
without the lambda,
the one that arises here.
Terms without lambda already.
Well, there's one
term here, which
is Schroedinger-like.
d dt of psi 1
is, in fact, equal
to order of lambda.
You have delta H
tilde psi 0 of t.
And the next one, ih
bar d dt of psi 2 of t--
that's lambda squared-- comes
from the derivative acting
here.
We have to look for
lambda squared here.
And I forgot this lambda.
And therefore, this time
you get delta H psi 1 of t.
In general, for lambda n, you
will get ih bar d dt of psi n--
I'll actually put n
plus 1, n plus 1 here--
is given by delta H acting
on the previous one.
So this will be simple.
Once you know psi 0, which is
a constant, you put it here.
This will be easily
solved as an integral.
Once you have psi
1, you put it here.
You easily solve psi 2 and
start solving one after another.
The fun thing is that you
can write these equations
explicitly.
And just even the first
order result, and sometimes
the second, give you all
the physics you want,
which we will explore in
the next few lectures.